i did a video recently about how i
believe stargate is going to be back on
the tv soon how i think amazon as the
new owners of mgm are going to be really
pushing to bring this franchise back and
that brad wright has been talking about
it for two years about how he's been
developing a new show
now
in that video i made a flippant comment
about sgu stargate universe and how i
always found it boring
i was challenged by one of my amazing
subscribers to go and watch it again
and to see whether it really is
as boring and as completely forgettable
as i said
so i'm going to take up that challenge
i have signed up to the mgm channel on
amazon
i have got the first episode all ready
to go um the remote control in my hand
i'm going to watch stargate universe and
i'm going to tell you exactly what i
think first thing i'm going to say about
this
is that on amazon they
rate out of 5 stars all the tv shows
there's been 1 354
ratings
on stargate universe season one and it
has four and a half stars
it has 7.8 out of 10 on idbm
maybe
i got stargate universe wrong
maybe
it just wasn't sg1
so i didn't appreciate it
so i'm gonna go into this with an open
mind
i'm hitting
play one of the interesting things i
know about this series actually is that
the uh
a lot of the sets are actually
reconfigured sets from
um sg1 that they just weren't using
anymore because the series had ended
[Music]
i actually really liked robert carlisle
as well i never really liked his
character in this series but i always
really loved
robert carlisle as an actor
and i can't remember the chap's name but
the um
the scientist the young guy in this
[Music]
just before we get started you know the
one thing i always thought about sgu
when it came out though
galactic reminded you before to critical
acclaim i wish that they were kind of
trying to um
copy it
you know they were trying to copy the
style and maybe that's why it didn't
work or maybe why i didn't like it
the opening sequence with the uh
with the seed ship coming across so and
us zooming i always loved how the back
end of it kind of looks like a pyramid
as well ming gnar isn't it it's
forgotten isn't it
let's see what i mean by these things
being quite forgettable
there's so many characters in it that
i've forgotten about oh there's a blonde
woman in it as well that i've forgotten
about and there's robert carla who just
smashed his face into the ground
[Music]
we're carlos looking down on the
pandemonium there's all the people from
flying through the gate
standing over it like
god like smirking at them almost
i never really quite know whether robert
carlisle is a good guy or a bad kind of
place serious do we that was quite
clever though
[Music]
it's not particularly likeable
it's a downside
just doing the flashback part
the eli character was the one i loved
the most and he was brilliant and i love
any opportunity for o'neill to be in
near stargate
when he told him on the way what if
happens if i don't sign this agreement
up to our spaceship okay and then they
do
the hammonds
which is just fantastic a little naughty
donnis davis just know everything don't
you
we also know that you are currently
eli just met chloe and he's been
immediately friend-zoned
straight back onto the um yeah
starship man
the e-line arc
is one of the only interesting things in
the early episodes
but now i've already seen that robert
carlyle's aboard the bridge
before everybody else
without waiting the design is clearly
ancient
in the truest sense of the world
launched
hundreds of thousands of years ago
nothing worse
faster than life
yet not through hyperspace so they've
just got to the icarus base
first time that this show is trying to
be a little bit different even though
the first series of sg-1 we had a bit of
nudity we have just had a little bit of
sex this is lieutenant scott always good
lieutenant scott is a little bugger but
he is going to be falling for chloe's
name spoilers
the icarus base
is probably where we're going to see i
might be tapping if i remember correctly
how fast you can start to take something
like this for granted
so if australia can instantly transport
you to another planet why do we fly
around a spaceship
something to do with how this one's tied
into the planet for power
apparently it's been modified
and dialed out because incoming
wormholes are too dangerous
you're the genius you'll probably tell
me better
all i did was solve a puzzle in a video
game
we figured out something dr rush has
been trying to figure out for months
which
by the way
a lot of people were glad to see
and of course you know come and tell
them
you ready for this colonel you just hear
the words sir oh i did it quite a while
ago can't tell what's in it which is
brilliant because i live in a town
called telford i grew up in a town
called telford so i always quite like
that thank you and lou diamond phillips
is brilliant
the colonel young's introduction
to this series
he came flying through
much more aggressive than everybody else
he's already injured already had a
seizure
and
we're getting hints to this other
medical issues
this time we're sure
the relationship between young i
embedded the mathematical problem we had
to solve into the game i then engineered
your solution to do a practical workable
application
we're already seeing hints of the
relationship between russia and eli as
well
even when
they mention
how eli solved russia's problem
rush immediately then has to come in and
go yeah but i put it into a practical
solution you might have thought of it
clever boy but i actually then
figured out how to use it
we also then see when the test is
happening through your equations again
everybody else wanted to shut it down
they were seeing fluctuations in the
power
and then
he doesn't want to think he's desperate
for it to work
that follows through
he then immediately blames eli
[Music]
it obviously does work though because
here we are
back
panic is starting to build up there
as the life supports failing
because i
dismissed this to you for so long i've
actually forgotten almost all of this
this is like having new stargates
i'm genuinely really enjoying it
it's very cool to see all the
302s
and death gliders flying around in the
attack on the pegasus station
the hints at all the different
relationships and things are interesting
and
i fear that's what happens on the rest
of the series that the first
episode is actually pretty exciting
because lot's happening
what i'm remembering is that
in their future episodes nothing really
happens
they're more worried about where's the
water you know how do we get the life
support working and things like that
it's all very clever and very stylistic
but
[Music]
one of the things i really love though
is the ambition of this show
the sets are phenomenal
mostly borrowed from sg1 but they're
still beautifully done
the actors
like robert carlisle
are proper
good
legitimate actors
[Music]
sg series were always quite ambitious
but this one actually really they put
all of their eggs in this basket
[Music]
illusion alliance attacking that's
fantastic and then
[Music]
we're about to say goodbye to amanda
tapping
i hope she comes back if they do another
sg series
she could really be the commander of
some some new
project or new
the attack starting the tune reaction to
the planet's core there's no way of
stopping that and any blast could easily
translate through an open world it's too
dangerous
dr rush has just come up with some
[ __ ] excuse why
they can't dial home and they have to
dial the ninth chevron we don't know
what's on the other side
[Music]
it's very tense
they've gone through because of this
attack
and they're not ready
i think it would have made for a better
show if they'd have gone through and
been prepared though
they got through the other side and they
realized they're on this ship and i
think but of course that's why they
couldn't do it if they'd gone through
and put them out through and everything
else then they'd have known what was on
the side and they probably wouldn't have
gone
[Music]
but then struggling on the other side is
one of the reasons maybe why the show is
a little bit boring at first
i love the detail i'm a geek i love the
oh way to get the ship from where do
there's how does this take why does that
work how does this work
but i think maybe they went a little bit
too far but hey i'm jumping ahead i'm
really enjoying this so far
but that's part one
i enjoyed it very much
the action was interesting the
play between the characters really
interesting everybody who is able we are
going to go to episode two
top to bottom team three they're gonna
try and figure out where they are now
back in the control
movie perhaps how are we supposed to
know what stanford um
right yes sir i work in the mess
i mean i did
don't touch yeah they're really not
ready for this
[Music]
oh they're using the stone so they've
been able to communicate back to the sgc
that's another throwback from sg one
episode
[Music]
i can't believe i forgot ming now is in
this
it's my favorite character from um
agents of shield she's brilliant in that
one of the things though
about this series is the ambition
and it's obviously
huge they've put so much
effort into the sets
the commitment to the show early on is
really visible we can see it on the
screen
and it's the
psychological or psychic communication
device which can connect two minds
across any distance it probably uses
quantum entanglement this could be the
engine room
in a few doors quantum mechanics uh
something i talk about my other channel
a brief history of mystery where we talk
about this scientific principle where
two objects can communicate to the
instantly regardless of the distance
you get one proton going left and the
other one goes right if you make the one
go right the other goes left and it
breaks all the laws of physics because
nothing's supposed to be able to travel
fast and speed like clean information
witchcraft
psychically to another one of the other
doctors
but what he hasn't done is uh told
anybody what you're doing
just again shows that
russia's constantly
got an agenda
oh they're losing it for a big haul
this is the first time we start to
realize that this [ __ ] is actually quite
badly damaged
okay it's been flying a really long time
so elo just found the keynotes
flying cameras
he just found a gumball machine that
dispenses drones
that's what his scholarship was he's
already actually done more that's
actually useful
than rush
the kinos can actually search the ship
and hopefully plug the gaps
or at least find out where their holes
are so that the life support can work
what's the
fine camera ball i'm calling it a
keynote don't ask
rush though is actually impressed with
the kingdom
it comes with a remote thought we could
use it to look around
what do you have
oh well it's not so good really um
these processing nuts
are scrubbers responsible for taking co2
from the air here here and here it's
indicating malfunction
i was a failure
[Music]
three days that water three weeks of
that food
so that's always your immediate problems
any survival situation
can i breathe
can i drink can i eat
at the moment this can i breathe
a bit of a problem
gree is an interesting character
complete nutter
was obviously in potential we don't know
why let's start the series to start the
episode so
now we have to wonder
is he actually crazy i think i found the
lead
oh is he just angry
but there's no control
maybe
very very interesting sort of uh
character arc
i forgot about symbols as well actually
i quite like the shuffles
i like the back end of the tail end
section this
we haven't found a way yet
seems to be operating
all the metal and stuff is rocked but
the uh the chairs actually seem quite
tidy
the leather is quite good nick
[Music]
well
that's not good
the fabric of the chairs actually
survived much better than most of the
ship
and colonel young's feet are twiddling
i'm looking forward to the relationship
between colonel young and rush actually
that was i do remember that from the
original watching it first time around
that explains the headache you already
had one
i'll find a way that's what these people
do and the doctor your hands are not
supposed to be here does he look a lot
like
we don't know it certainly it looks like
it never battle at least an insult
it's a very well thought through series
this kind of reminds me a little bit of
the end the martian
yes it is
it's one of those things that you come
away go in that's very very clever
i really thought through every problem
the thing i would say is though the
martian had an element of humor to it
it was funny in places accelerate
sga it's really harder to breathe the
moral dilemma here if somebody has to go
on board shuttle to shut the door but
then we'll suffocate we'll die
it's interesting
the chloe capture merely goes you're not
going to ask somebody to sacrifice
themselves it's not going to happen it's
morally objectionable
question makes the great point
politicians ask the military to
sacrifice themselves every single day
help me
colonel young
volunteering today
no sir
i know
you can have me court martial when we
get home but i am not
gonna help you kill yourself
if the senator does this and kills
himself that's the first time a senator
or politician has ever done anything
good
like ever
definitely anything brave
definitely modern politicians anyway
politicians going to do something good
so that's why this series failed it's
completely unbelievable
it doesn't look like to be fair
i like the doors on this series as well
and they come down at that semi-circular
interlocking element to them
it's a proper
sort of like an airlock
so very ancient very solid you know it's
not like a star trek i think this is
very modern and
almost look quite flimsy these
the whole
ship design is very very solid
[Music]
i think they'd be like i don't even see
an airplane when somebody's freaking out
and they all end up and somebody also
slaps them calm down
and
that's what would actually happen in
this case
everybody on here would be forming an
orderly clean queue to beat the [ __ ] out
of russia at this point
he's not sorry
he was a good man
he certainly wouldn't have been my
choice but you must realize
none of this was my fault
i didn't create this situation that
forced us here
he didn't create the situation but he
kind of did
he's a psycho he actually
needs this more than he needs
to survive he's actually put in what he
might discover
on the ship brush this is
before the lives of everybody else
this armstrong and that's really
follows through
the two series
it's not a psycho
but his priorities
could be the most important discovery
clearly
so i've just finished part two
part three still to go
i open the question of this episode
is stargate universe as boring as i
remember well the first two episodes
weren't the first two episodes were
very entertaining indeed and i enjoyed
them greatly
just part three to go
so the destiny has fallen out of fdl
it knows
what the crew and its new crew needs and
has
activated the stargate sending them to a
planet
that it believes has what they need
very interesting
so let's see what happens
the other one thing i thought about
those is they're putting together this
away team eli taking the lead
was um i'm looking in the background and
see which one's wearing the red shirt
which one's uh definitely gonna die on
this away mission
there's a couple of characters there
that i suspect
we're not going to see again
but hey
let's keep going and let's see what
happens
okay so
fish and chips
part three
destiny
the design is clearly ancient launched
hundreds of thousands of years ago
there's a last time on stargate sgu bit
we're on a ship we have no idea where we
are in relation to earth so now we're
getting into the
we're all gonna die face
and they're all getting ready to say
goodbye
i'm using the stones to telepathically
communicate across
hundreds of thousands of lightings
um
eli just cracked his first joke
i was expecting to see the statue of
liberty coming over that last june that
beautiful white desert that they're in
let's start the third series looking for
the
whatever they can use to scrub the co2
again the ambition of the series
way way up there the cost the production
cost must have been through the roof
and i suspect that's probably why the
series got cancelled at the end of the
second series because the viewing
figures never really met the
expectations
every sci-fi series though the first two
series aren't very good
voyager first two series rubbish until
seven of nine turned up and fighting
species seven four six two
it was boring
very forgetful
the first two series of tng weren't very
good
deep space nine until the defiant turned
up
and the pegasus got destroyed
it wasn't really particularly
interesting
similar sort of problem with this
with this series really of all those
series there's too much setting up too
much talking too much having a chat
about everything's going wrong or what
we need to do to set up
instead of actually just like
being interesting and cracking on with
the story
it's not just star trek that suffered
from that there was either
the first series of battle on five was
terrible
we were able to download it again
battle star galactica started with that
mini series film that was incredible i'm
going to watch along with it but then
actually to be fair it just slowly got
more boring because it went on roughly
nine hours beautifully filmed again
nothing happened
another problem with sgu though is that
the protagonist isn't there
i know a bad guy's gonna turn up in a
couple of episodes but
i can't remember anything about that bad
guy i understand that there are others
in range
in every good sci-fi series the bad guy
is as important as the good guy
you know the borg made tng many voyages
to be fair there has to be a good reason
why these are the gem haddad and the
dominion were a great adversary for the
ds9 series
the sith in star wars
terminator in the terminator series
everything the predator the predator
series
bad guy
makes the sci-fi series just as much as
anything else
that's something else sgu was missing to
a large degree because
you know in the first series survival is
the enemy all right come on let's go hey
makes a great bear grylls episode but
doesn't really make for a great sci-fi
series
eli looks more like a cherry tomato the
longer the episode goes on
he's not a man that's built for the
desert in the warm conditions i feel
but they found the lime
thanks to the willow the wisp
character
[Music]
if he can survive long enough to get a
massive bag full of heavy line
back to the gate
but gree is there looking
and found him yeah
now all i could do is get back before
the stargate closes and destiny heads
off
here they come
so one thing is really is i don't like
the new stargates in this series
one of the reasons why i like the old
star game from sg1
was the mechanical nature of it when the
chevron encoded
and it opened up and everything now it
just sort of spins around and lights up
it's kind of digital version of the
stargate
i liked it before
but they needed to change i suppose to
get that different feeling especially
for a different time
[Music]
so dr russian for this brilliant idea
that he likes to put his arm into the
event horizon but wait
as they run out of time and the destiny
is about to leave
he's hoping there's some sort of safety
protocol
in place so that the
destiny won't leave
as the 12-hour time frame runs out
or eli's believes are
[Music]
looks like dr rush's
theory is panned out
and eli still got both arms happy days i
like i quite like this so there's a
plasma surgeon
every time they come back through the
gate
again it's just that slight difference
and destiny is often travels once again
hopefully head into somewhere they've
got water next
if you haven't watched stargate sgu in a
long time like me
go find it
watch it
you'll
enjoy i'll be back with future episodes
looking back at sgu as i go through the
series
and i'm going to come back at the end of
the series once i finally get through to
watching all 40 episodes
and i'm going to tell you the answer to
the question that started this video
is the sgu just boring
thank you very much and if you are new
to the channel please don't forget to
like and subscribe hit that bell
notification share the video
we're a new channel
help us grow just the way it is
thanks see you next time
[Music]